all right let's just do it let's just do
it let's just do it but we're gonna
close our window so our neighbors can
hear us just doing it
[Music]
oh no hi my name is different now
welcome to my kitchen which means only
one
thing i have a shelter and that's what
we all need right now
and the other thing it means is that
we're cooking today we're in it we're
doing it we're very excited because the
world is falling apart and we can't
control it nobody knows but
everyone knows what to do what to do
what the [ __ ] do we do
should i start writing music it's time
for another hello fresh
cooking video today you guys have seen
me make a million hello fresh meals
that is an exaggerated number the world
is spreading a lot of information lately
and it's good to admit when you've
exaggerated some facts
i've done a lot of hellofresh cooking
videos in the past where
i follow the recipe and i make a meal
and you watch it happen
and i wanted to make it a little bit
more interesting today
so i've decided i'm not following the
recipe
i haven't even checked with hellofresh
if that's okay for me to do in this
video but we're just gonna do it
hellofresh is a subscription meal
service where they basically
send you pre-packaged ingredients and
you can make delicious
chef curated meals the one thing i will
follow
are the talking points that they've
graciously asked me to share with you
they have 22
plus seasonal chef curated meals that
you can choose from
on a weekly or bi-weekly basis there's
something for everyone with them they
got low-calorie meals family-friendly
meals yeah their
meals and they streamline everything for
you they send you pre-packaged
ingredients
so there's less waste and you can get
these meals on the table in 30 minutes
so they say this is the only brown paper
bag that i trust that gets delivered to
my front doorstep
that i know has something i want inside
of it also they're very easy you can
change your delivery days you can change
your meal preferences
it's all there for you they give you
recipe cards with every
recipe that have six steps on them so
it's foolproof i'm a little bit bored by
it being foolproof so today
i am testing myself to make a hello
fresh recipe
without the recipe
this is metaphorical of everything
that's happening in the world right now
we're all trying to make ourselves
something but we're not all following
the same recipe is that that's the
that's the
that's the metaphor that i'm i'm just
i'm reaching guys
child's pose today i'm gonna make
chimichurri
pork tenderloin that looks beautiful in
theory i have not looked at
any of the anything i mean i barely look
at the recipe card
when i actually decide to use the recipe
so this shouldn't be that different i
also feel like i'm
pretty much an expert at hellofresh now
so this should be pretty easy for me to
figure out how to do
it's kind of like i've created my own
escape room for myself
wow i'm doing my own escape room we'll
see future grace i'm sorry i feel like
you're gonna have a lot of stress but
right now we're pretty good
stay present let's just dive into it
shall we everything i need is in this
bag
that sounds like a katy perry song or
something a drug addict says
no eggs wow treasure
these are my escape room hints this is
also a fun idea if you've decided to
quarantine yourself
to keep your brain occupied or you can
watch 12 hours of life at their lock up
and if you've already done that maybe do
this first things first i'm going to
wash my
hands a lot of times i don't do that in
these videos but this time i'm doing it
i'm not doing it for you i'm doing it
for me so don't
even think that you've had an influence
on me please like and subscribe and
never
stop watching my videos i'm doing it for
longer than i normally do okay so i got
some pots and pans and this thing out
because i assume i need those
tools how has the food network not work
wow that's a freudian slip food not work
wow how does the food network not have a
show like this already
i'm pitching it informally to the food
network it's my idea escape room cooking
guy fieri you and me it'd just be roots
on roots on roots on route and roots i
got a knife
we got rice here assuming i have to do
my rice
first i don't know how much water to
rice i'm gonna put three quarters a cup
of water
in a pot and boil it with the rice
ignore how non-confident i look in my
face and just trust
my measuring glass in here excuse me do
you have a measuring class
oh i solved the first hint
do i need more water don't hesitate just
do
isn't that what the dalai lama says i'm
gonna add a little oil to this
everything's better when it's lubricated
good luck now i got these carrots we're
gonna peel the carrots
i'm nailing this i think they say don't
touch your face these days
do you have my peeler you do wow you
hardy little
bastards sometimes when you spend too
much time at home you find yourself
talking
too casually to all your inanimate
objects it's charming how are you guys
holding up you doing okay
everyone has a healthy amount of freak
out at the ready
this is what we call small talk so these
carrots look like they've been roasted
and they look like they've been cut i'm
assuming they're gonna have to go in the
oven
i'm gonna preheat the oven to like
3.75 you know when you're not following
a recipe
technically you're never wrong 375 let's
cut these carrots they look like they're
cut
kind of on a slant being on a slant is
very trendy right now
this is also kind of a fun like date
night activity too if you guys
each took a recipe and tried to blindly
make it and you see whose is better
relationships are always better when
you're constantly competing against each
other these are gonna go
on a baking sheet because that's the
kind of thing that goes in the oven
that seems successful i so badly want to
like turn that over but
i'm not going to ground cumin chili
flakes honey garlic we have a lime
and cilantro i know carrots cook well
with honey and it looks like they have
chili flakes on them
i'm gonna put honey salt and pepper and
chili flakes on them
i'm not wrong because i'm not checking
we're gonna put a drizzle of olive oil
on these carrots i think the rice needs
way more water the rice looks way too
dry i'm putting more water in i can do
whatever i want it didn't even boil it
just started burning i thought the rice
would be the easiest part
i'm feeling what's the opposite of
confidence that
okay so we're putting some olive oil on
let's wash our hands again that's the
only thing i know is safe these days our
rice is boiling so we're gonna put it
down to simmer okay we're gonna drizzle
some honey on these carrots
our honey and olive oil supposed to go
together chili flakes and we're gonna
put some ground cumin
on cumin is like smoky and like honey is
sweet so maybe it's gonna be like like
just a child holding a cigar
that old adage the cool thing about
hellofresh is that when you do
follow the recipe which is very easy you
get really great results but we love to
create challenges for ourselves we're
what one might call
a self saboteur it's pretty cool let's
wash our hands again
okay our oven is ready so i think we're
gonna put our carrots in put our carrots
in for
a period of time until they start
looking roasted like they do on this
photo
now let's work on the meat there's no
one to answer you
so the pork looks like it's cooked and
then it's got a chimichurri sauce on it
let's chop up some cilantro
something very cathartic about this
right now we got our cilantro leaves
let's put this
in a little bowl shall we oh i didn't
put salt and pepper on the carrots we
got some salt and some pepper that might
be the only right thing i do let's put a
timer on for 10 minutes
you have this garlic i'm assuming this
goes in the chimichurri sauce garlic
cilantro
probably some olive oil salt pepper
chili flakes cumin i'm just naming the
ingredients they gave me
has everyone been getting equal parts
mad and sad about everything recently
i'm glad you're here because i hope that
this can distract you from
the trials and tribulations of your
everyday life who doesn't find
joy in watching someone else struggle to
put the garlic
in with the cilantro the camera stopped
recording because it's already been 30
minutes so
but by editing you don't know it's been
like 10 minutes let's put some olive oil
in with this cilantro and garlic let's
put salt and pepper in
okay let's mix this up that looks like a
sauce lime
ow ow i have cuts all over my fingers
everything gets chili flakes that
looks like the green stuff that's on the
thing okay the one
glaring thing is the meat i'm assuming
we just cooked this in a pan
maybe we put some salt and pepper on it
the carrots are doing
i don't know they're having a party like
a bunch of middle schoolers partying in
someone's basement i'm gonna let them do
their thing i'm not even gonna
check on them i don't wanna know get our
meat out and then pat
it everything about this seems wrong and
that's okay because we don't know what
right is
oh i'm so sorry vegetarians you can get
vegetarian options on hellofresh wash
your hands
pat our meat dry let's season with salt
and pepper salt
pepper now let's put some oil in the pan
yeah i'm a little all over the place but
i trust the process
actually i don't trust the process
should we put some cumin on it i'm gonna
put some cumin
okay let's put our meat in the pan and
cook it
are you trying to get in for free i need
to see some id put our meat in the pan
and cook it till
that sounds nice we're gonna put salt
and pepper on the other side don't worry
i'm using my clean hand wash your hands
i don't know how to feel about what's
happening right now let's add some cumin
to the chimichurri and just try to push
down
all of our anxiety something's good i
think
about it okay we have carrots in the
oven we have meat in a pan
and we have rice in a pot
is any of it doing the things that it's
supposed to do
um we don't have to answer that we're
our own publicist and
we're our own interviewer and we don't
have to answer anything
that we've asked ourselves and this is
how someone slowly descends into madness
i feel great about this
parents look like they've been cooking
but they're proud i think they need
longer
i'm going to turn the meat over because
it it's cooking i guess
following recipes has its benefits but
look how fun and carefree we are
my whole house is filling the smell
everything's great oh the battery's
dying in the camera the symbolism
in this entire video wow but here's a
real lesson to you guys
you can do anything you put your mind to
will it come out as intended no
but does that mean it's not worth it
i'm bored with my own inspirational
conversation
i really don't know how long the meat is
supposed to cook for and i don't
really want to give myself food
poisoning today there's lots of smoke in
this kitchen we're gonna pull the
carrots out but good thing i like my
carrots like i like a
good sense of humor dry this is like if
your friend asked you if they should get
bangs and you were like yes
and you went with them for moral support
and then they got bangs and then you
just kind of
both sit and deal with the fact that
you're kind of responsible for this
honestly you look great the pork has
been cooking for more than at least one
minute so we're gonna pull it out now
like what you should do with your pork
pull it out before it's too late look at
that that looks like cooked meat
from the outside successful lives are
always based
on only outside appearances okay we're
gonna let the pork rest for a second
because you've been through it honestly
our rice doesn't look that bad
we might have done something okay i'm
gonna plate this up and see how close we
get to our actual vision board here we
go i'm just going to wash my hands again
because i'm stressed out and this has
become
like it seems like the right thing to do
grace is a little wet you want one thing
on this plate that's a little wet
wow you don't look um that's a little
pink in the middle we're gonna cook the
meat a little
more now it's like it's made to order
also i think elliot's on his way home so
he might be able to taste test this for
us and he'll never know
that we just did this blindly and that
we might be giving him food poisoning
he'll just think i'm being a really
sweet girlfriend oh my god
okay hold on this might be actually okay
oh my god
all right take a look at this
this is how she looks in her tinder
picture and then this is how she looks
when she shows up and you're like oh my
god she's not a liar and then you get to
know her and you realize
wow there was a lot of stress and trauma
that got you to this you are really
masking a lot of pain
i think we might have kind of done this
successfully
at least it looks edible and it looks
like
what it's supposed to look like i'm
going to taste this before i do you know
this already if you don't get ready you
can get 10 free meals from hellofresh by
going to hellofresh.com
using the promo code rice helbig 10 10
free meals that includes free shipping
by going to hellofresh.com using the
promo code grace gracehelbig10
i'm gonna try it the cool thing about
this is i don't know what it's supposed
to taste like
and also i can lie to you isn't that the
fun thing about people that make
internet videos we can just splat out
lie to you let's try it
it tastes good that tasted pretty good
but also i have a trash can palette
let's try a carrot carrots definitely
haven't been cooked they're pretty
pretty fat
that's not that bad either did i do this
okay oh there's the red pepper flake
you know you've done food well when it
feels like it's just slapping you in the
throat all the way down okay
the sound of a delicious meal i'm proud
of myself i did it
and you'll never know if i didn't do it
because maybe i'm lying to you i
but i'm not i can't i wouldn't i really
think i did this and i have an odd sense
of pride and also a healthy level of
anxiety about
the future of my stomach let me see how
it was supposed to be cooked oh
the meat was supposed to go in the oven
okay supposed to season the pork with
the cumin
okay so we did some things wrong but
it's all going to the same place anyway
and it looks like the photo and that's
all that matters
in dating and cooking one thing i've
learned is you'll never ever
ever go wrong by judging a book solely
by its cover thank you guys so much for
watching if you like this video give it
a thumbs up and subscribe to this
youtube channel i make videos
and i encourage you to go get hello
fresh you won't believe what happens
when you follow a recipe the level of
anxiety and stress surrounding a fun
activity
is way lower a life without stress or
anxiety
who wants it i don't know ah
perfect timing you look so cute thank
you
and yes i was cooking hi
hi gonna put your backpack down and
taste it yeah we did it
i'm so glad we had this time together me
too this looks really good
it does look really good what is this
hellofresh
it is wow that's so neat is do you know
anywhere i can find this
uh they already know is it good
really mm-hmm because i did it without
following the recipe
great really i don't even know if that's
how the meat is supposed to be cooked i
don't know any of it
george grubb i is it okay
yeah cool
see ya